>> Laura: THE NONFOX MEDIA IS
ABUZZ WITH THE LATEST SO-CALLED
BOMBSHELL FROM MICHAEL AVENATTI,
AN ATTORNEY FOR @IngrahamAngle
STAR STORMY DANIELS.
HE'S CLAIMING THAT THE COMPANY
CONTROLLED BY A RUSSIAN
BILLIONAIRE PLAYED THE
PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL ATTORNEY
MICHAEL COHEN HALF-MILLION
DOLLARS.
WHICH COHEN COULD'VE USED THEM
TO PAY STORMY DANIELS.
OKAY, LET'S SLOW DOWN HERE.
FIRST CONSIDER THE SOURCE.
AVENATTI AMONG OTHER MISTRUTHS,
CLAIMED JUST LAST WEEK, THAT
HE KNEW FOR A FACT THAT THE FBI
HAD WIRETAPPED COHEN.
>> I DON'T THINK WE ARE GOING TO
FIND OUT THAT THIS WAS CONFINED
JUST TO EMAIL VOICE WIRETAPPED.
I THINK MY UNDERSTANDING IS THEY
WEREN'T WIRETAPPING TEXT MESSAGE
COMMUNICATIONS FOR THE WEEKS
LEADING UP TO THE FBI RAIDS.
>> IS THAT A PIECE OF
INFORMATION YOU'VE COME INTO IN
THE COURSE OF YOUR WORK ON THIS
CASE OR ARE YOU SPECULATING?
SPEAK I'M NOT SPECULATIVE.
IT'S A FACT.
>> Laura: AS WE KNOW, THE IT
WASN'T A FACT.
THERE WAS NO TEXT MESSAGE FAILS.
DIDN'T HAPPEN.
NOW WE HAVE MORE THAN AVENATTI
COMMITTED A MAJOR BLUNDER WITH
HIS SO-CALLED SCOOP YESTERDAY.
"THE DAILY CALLER" IS REPORTING
THAT HE HAS A SEVEN PAGE DOSSIER
WITH A LIST OF PAYMENTS
SUPPOSEDLY MADE TO TERMS LAWYER
AND IT CITES THE WRONG MICHAEL
COHEN, A FAIRLY WELL-KNOWN NAME,
MICHAEL COHEN.
A LOT OF MICHAEL COHENS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
REPORTING THAT SOME OF THE
PAYMENTS WERE MADE TEN MEN NAMED
MICHAEL COHEN WHO HAVE NO
AFFILIATION WITH DRUM.
ON TOP OF ALL THAT,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" REPORTS
THAT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL IS
INVESTIGATING JUST HOW AVENATTI
OBTAINED COHEN'S BANKING
RECORDS.
FOR MORE, LET'S CONSULT WITH
FOX NEWS CAN OF IT ARE BYRON
YORK DEPUTY ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY GENERAL BOB ROBERT
DRISCOLL.
GENTLEMEN, GRADY C.
BYRON, THERE'S BEEN QUITE A FEW
MISTRUTHS STATED BY MICHAEL
AVENATTI WHO WAS BROUGHT ONTO
SOME OF THESE OTHER NETWORKS,
ALMOST LIKE AN ANALYST.
THEY ALMOST FORGET THAT HE'S
REPRESENTING A CLIENT.
INSTEAD, HE SAYS SOMETHING AND
THEY, THE CHIRON'S, TRUMP, COHEN
BOMBSHELL, RUSSIAN OLIGARCH
WITHOUT LOOKING INTO THE
DETAILS.
IT'S WILD.
>> HAS BEEN BRAGGING ABOUT HIS
TV APPEARANCES.
BRINGING INFORMATION, PERHAPS
CONFIDENTIAL, FINANCIAL
INFORMATION ABOUT MICHAEL COHEN.
ONE OF THE BIG THING, THE
HEADLINES IS RUSSIA, RUSSIA,